capacité
je l'ai vu j'y suis allé
c'est organique c'est des rochers
ça virevolte c'est vivant c'est
électrique c'est sauvage je l'ai vu j'y
suis allé c'est des
rugissements c'est furieux
ça grandit c'est farfelu
c'est électrique c'est sauvage des
centaines et des milliers et des millions  et
des milliards des milliards et des
milliards des milliards de milliards de novas
supernovas hypernovas rayons
gamma ce sont des
rayons X en expansion explosant s'écrasant
et dansant fracassant et soufflant
et tout se
passe au-dessus de nos têtes tout se passe
au-dessus de nos têtes tout
se passe au-dessus de nos têtes
j'ai vu  c'est ce que j'ai été là-bas
c'est violent c'est c'est
rapide c'est
brillant
c'est électrique c'est sauvage
je l'ai vu j'y suis allé
formidable c'est profond c'est magnifique c'est
brutal c'est
électrique c'est sauvage des
centaines et des milliers et des millions et des milliards des milliards
et des zillions des milliards x
-rayons,
tout s'étend, explose, écrase
et danse, écrase et souffle
et tout se passe au-dessus de nos têtes,
tout se passe par-dessus les rayons
X, les rayons X, les
rayons X,
ça